[Applaudissements]
belle prothèse n'est ce pas c'est vrai
que j'y suis très attaché je trouve que
elles me font un certain style
d'ailleurs je vais être honnête
en fait c'est surtout pour le style que
je l'aimais j'en ai pas vraiment besoin
je vais les ranger ah oui c'est vrai que
j'ai une autre prothèse aussi mais en
fait pour moi
elles sont pas si différentes montrer
cette prothèse s'y est montrée celle là
c'est exactement la même chose on peut
choisir sa monture de lunettes pourquoi
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas choisir une
coque pour sa prothèse de jambe
je pense que c'est important de montrer
ma prothèse parce que oui je suis comme
ça tous les jours ma prothèse est
toujours visible
je pense que c'est important d'expliquer
aux enfants qui me posent des questions
dans la rue que j'ai eu une maladie que
j'ai dû me faire amputer mais
qu'aujourd'hui je suis plus malade et je
peut de nouveau marcher je pense que
c'est important de montrer qu'en 2019 on
peut avoir le sourire faire des études
sortir en boîte même avoir une sexualité
malgré un handicap handicap
en fait c'est un mot que j'aime pas trop
je trouve qu'il veut tout et rien dire
mais comme dans le cadre de mes études
on m'apprend à ne pas rester dans le
j'aime ou je n'aime pas j'ai décidé
d'aller un petit peu plus loin handicap
infirmité ou déficience congénitale ou
acquise
ouais
des avantages souvent naturel
infériorité qu'on doit supporter bon
d'accord je suis attendait mais en fait
qui m'intéresse vraiment c'est la
première définition que fait le larousse
du mot handicap
le larousse nous dit handicap de points
épreuve dans laquelle les concurrents
reçoivent ou rendent une avance de sorte
qu'ils aient tous des chances égales de
victoire malgré leurs différences c'est
un petit peu compliqué en fait le
handicap c'est une épreuve dans laquelle
on a tous les mêmes chances
le handicap c'est l'égalité des chances
ça vient de hand in cape littéralement
la main dans un chapeau en fait c'était
un jeu de hasard britannique qui
consistait à piochés au hasard dans un
chapeau un objet ou une somme d'argent
déposée par un autre joueur
le handicap c'est rétablir le hasard
rétablir l'égalité des chances on prend
de plus en plus conscience du besoin de
rétablir l'égalité des chances dans nos
sociétés dans les médias à la télé au
cinéma dans les publicités
on voit de plus en plus de personnes en
situation de handicap
est ce qu'on en fait pas un petit peu
trop
c'est vrai que le handicap on dirait que
c'est à la mode
c'est pour certains devenu un véritable
outil marketing stéphane amato qui est
un chercheur en sciences de
l'information communication à
l'université de toulon a récemment
publié un article qui traite en partie
de ce sujet son article nous rappelle
aussi à quel point le handicap est
protéiforme
moi mon handicap m'apporte énormément
mais c'est pas pour ça que vous devez
penser que c'est le cas pour tout le
monde j'ai un handicap parmi des
centaines
je suis jeune plutôt beau gosse enfin au
moins selon ma mère
et surtout je suis en bonne santé déjà
rien qu'avec ça j'ai un avantage sur
beaucoup ont dit que 80% des handicaps
sont invisibles
c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à vouloir
toujours associé une image un mot le
problème c'est que bien souvent cette
image
eh bien elle ne définit qu'une toute
partie toute petite partie du mot tenez
par exemple quand je dis handicap etc on
me répond ça il ya moi j'aimerais
ajouter ça ça ça et encore il en
manquerait énormément je suis très
heureux de prendre la parole aujourd'hui
je suis très heureux par exemple que le
handisport sont de plus en plus
médiatisées tenait aux derniers jeux
paralympiques d'hiver à pyongyang
les chaînes françaises publiques ont
diffusé plus de 100 heures de la
compétition
c'est énorme c'est génial alors certains
diront que le handisport ces vendeurs
certains diront qu'on utilise les
handicaps comme un outil marketing
en attendant si ça peut permettre à des
gens de continuer à rêver malgré leur
handicap et moi je peux pas penser que
la médiatisation du handisport puisse
être une mauvaise chose
malgré tout malgré que la médiatisation
du handisport soit globalement une bonne
chose il faut garder à l'esprit qu'on
n'est pas tous logés à la même enseigne
tous les handicapés ne sont pas tous
logés à la même enseigne
enfin bon je vous parle de handicap
depuis tout à l'heure alors que je vous
ai dit que je n'aimais pas trop ce mot
en fait je le trouve trop générale et je
vais vous parler de quelque chose de
plus restreint que je maîtrise un petit
peu mieux je vais vous parler de
l'amputation est ce que vous savez de
quand date la première amputation
la première amputation remontrer à il ya
7000 ans on a retrouvé un squelette qui
portent des marques claire d'amputations
sur l'humérus
alors pour ceux qui dormaient en cours
de biologie l'humérus celle à loos entre
le coude et l'épaule ce qui est génial
c'est que ce squelette porte également
des marques de cicatrisation
en fait ça veut dire qu'il ya 7000 ans
il ya un homme qui a survécu à une
amputation
alors j'imagine que malgré tout les
conditions d'hygiène de l'époque n'était
pas forcément au top et que si j'avais
eu mon cancer il ya 7000 ans je serais
peut-être pas dans le même état qu
aujourd'hui la médecine a bien évolué
déjà on pratique les amputations sous
anesthésie ouf je l'échappée belle mais
surtout surtout depuis le 16e siècle
on a eu la sublime idée de ligaturer les
artères de l'est recouvre en fait je dit
on on s'est en fait ce monsieur
ambroise paré chirurgien anatomiste
parce qu'avant lui la seule solution
qu'on avait pour refermer les membres
amputés
c'était la cautérisation comment vous
expliquer la cautérisation simplement
concrètement on coupe on brûle et on
croise les doigts pour que ça ne
s'infecte pas et encore pour croiser les
doigts et vaut mieux que ce ne soit pas
une amputation de la main la médecine
évolue très vite donc il a fallu à peine
une heure à l'équipe de chirurgiens de
tours pour m'amputer et former un mois
ce qui me permet d'être appareillé de
porter une prothèse tous les jours la
médecine évolue vite mais ce qui évolue
encore plus vite
c'est la technologie dans les années 60
on a inventé les genoux à vérins
hydrauliques
en fait ce sont des prothèses de genoux
qui permettent grâce à un vérin un
certain contrôle de la flexion et de
l'extension du genou le genou que j'ai
aujourd'hui
il est équipé d'un microprocesseur
en fait c'est un mini ordinateur qui
captent interprète mes mouvements et
donne la meilleure réponse possible
ce mini ordinateur il me permet d'avoir
des mouvements plus fluides plus
agréable et donc de retrouver une vie
quotidienne normale
mieux encore mon genou apprend plus je
marche avec lui plus il est capable de
prévoir mes mouvements et donc de donner
la meilleure réponse possible et je peux
même le diriger via mon téléphone grâce
au bluetooth
c'est pas une blague on va de plus en
plus loin avec les prothèses
il existe même aujourd'hui des prothèses
de bras bionique commander directement
par le cerveau certains essayiste
transhumanistes pense que d'ici quelques
années vous rêverez tous de vous faire
amputer pour profiter des dernières
technologies à la mode
qui n'a jamais rêvé d'avoir les
propulseurs d'iron man ou les bras
extensible de l'inspecteur gadget et
pourtant il pourrait vraiment vous
manqué une petite chose les sensations
on arrive bien à récupérer des
informations du cerveau pour contrôler
des membres bionique en revanche
récupérer des sensations sur une
prothèse pour les retransmettre au
cerveau
c'est plus compliqué on n'y est pas
encore et pourtant on fait déjà des
choses formidables avec les prothèses
juger' qui est un double amputé tibial
comme vous pouvez le voir il a également
la particularité d'être ingénieur om
haïti il s'est lui même avec son équipe
de recherche
conçu des prothèses qui lui permettent
de marcher courir sauter danser de façon
aussi précise que vous pourriez presque
en être jaloux
un autre exemple oscar pistorius il a
couru avec les valides aux championnats
du monde de 2011 et aux jeux olympiques
de 2012
alors oui évidemment il est aussi connu
pour avoir été condamné pour le meurtre
de sa femme mais c'est pas ça qui nous
intéresse ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
monsieur pistes aux russes vient
remettre en question la hiérarchie a
priori des performances entre handisport
est valide
alors est-ce qu'on devrait pousser tous
les handisportifs à courir avec les
valides
j'en sais rien je pas vraiment sûr que
ce soit une bonne idée
est ce qu'avec ses lames de carbone
oscar pistorius avait un avantage sur
ses concurrents
j'ai du mal à me faire un avis il ya eu
des expertises des contre expertises qui
disent oui ou non en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que pistorius il ne peut pas
se faire d'entorse à la cheville
et oui on va de plus en plus loin avec
les prothèses partout dans le monde
des designers travaillent pour rendre
les prothèses plus adapté et plus
fonctionnel quitte parfois à dépasser
les limites de ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer pour des humains normaux
tenez par exemple est ce que vous
arrivez à faire ça vous
et oui ça vous en bouche un coin
on a par exemple l'athlète français de
handisport arnaud assoumani qui
travaille avec un ancien designer
automobile pour créer une prothèse
demain qui pourra intégrer une clé usb
une enceinte bluetooth des led et les
possibilités sont infinies
un autre exemple nicolas huchet qu'on
voit ici lui il utilise l'impression 3d
pour rendre les prothèses plus
accessibles les plans de ces prothèses
sont disponibles gratuitement et
téléchargeable sur internet
encore une fois c'est la technologie qui
vient au service de l'égalité des
chances
on vient rétablir le hasard le fameux
end inocap la main dans une balle à la
main dans la prothèse pour le coup en
fait la prothèse ça peut même devenir un
accessoire de mode
pensez aux lunettes moi pour mon
anniversaire j'ai commandé une coque
noire avec des petites touches dorées ah
oui on peut être amputés et malgré tout
qu'au quai en fête au delà de la
coquetterie
je pense que mon amputation m'apporte
une telle motivation que si aujourd'hui
on me proposait de récupérer ma jambe
j'ai l'intimé conviction que je
refuserais ma prothèse c'est ma force
c'est ma force parce que j'en joue parce
que j'en suis fier et parce que dans une
certaine mesure
j'arrive à un moment où avoir une
prothèse et un sourire c'est à la mode
et moi j'ai décidé d'en profiter merci
[Applaudissements]